The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and OpenCourseWare in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I'll start a little formally.
That this is 18.086 in
Spring semester of 2006.
And we're lucky to have it
videotaped for OpenCourseWare.
So, let me begin by
remembering the main topics
from what you might call the
first half, 18.085, the Fall
course.
And then, most important
to us, so it gets a star,
are the main topics
for this course.
So 18.085 began with
applied linear algebra.
The discrete equations
of mechanics,
and physics and engineering.
And the type of matrices
that it involved,
so we learned what positive
definite matrices are.
Then the center of the course
was differential equations.
Ordinary differential
equations, so that
was 1D, partial differential
equations like Laplace,
that was 2D, with
boundary values.
So that led to
systems of equations.
And then the third big
topic was Fourier methods.
All of Fourier ideas: series,
integrals discrete transform.
So that's like the first
half of the course.
Well, that's 18.085.
OK.
And here we are.
So this course has,
also, three major topics.
The first, the one
we start on today,
is differential equations that
start from initial values.
So I'm thinking of the wave
equation, where we're given
the displacement of velocity.
The heat equation.
Black-Scholes equation,
which comes from finance,
is a version of
the heat equation.
Ordinary differential equations,
that's going to be today.
And non-linear equations,
Navier-Stokes ultimately.
But not heavily Navier-Stokes.
So this is where we begin.
And then, a second big
topic is how to solve.
Because this course
is really applied
math and scientific computing.
The second big topic is, how do
you solve a large linear system
A*x equal b?
Do you do it by direct
methods, elimination?
With renumbering
of nodes, and there
are lots of tricks that makes
elimination very successful.
Or do you do it by
iterative methods?
Multi-grid is one.
So this is really modern
scientific computing
we're talking about.
We're really at the point
where people are computing.
And then the third topic,
which is a little different,
is optimization, minimization.
Linear programming would be one
example, but among many, many.
So that's a major
area in applied math.
OK.
So this is our topic,
differential equations.
And I was asked before
the tape started
about my own background.
And my thesis was in this topic.
Because a key question
will be stability.
Is the difference method stable?
You'll see that that's a
requirement to be any good.
You really have
to sort out what--
and that usually puts a
limitation on the time step.
So we're going to
have a time step.
And it may be limited by the
requirement of stability.
And the fact that stability
and convergence-- success
of the method-- are
so intimately linked.
There was a key paper by Lax and
Richtmyer that we'll look at.
It's known now as the Lax
Equivalence Theorem, stability
and convergence.
We'll see it in detail.
Actually when I was a grad
student, by good chance,
there was a seminar, and I was
asked to report on some paper
and it happened to be that one.
And I just, looking back,
think, gosh, I was lucky.
Because that paper,
the Lax-Richtmyer paper
with the Lax
Equivalence Theorem,
set the question of stability.
And then years of effort
went into finding tests
for stability-- how do you
decide, is the method stable?
So we'll see some of that.
OK.
Since then I've worked
on other things,
well, wavelets would be one
that relates to Fourier.
And other topics too.
And lots of linear algebra.
But it's a pleasure to look
back to the beginning of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK.
So that's the
OpenCourseWare site
which does have
the course outline,
and other information
about the course.
Some of which I have mentioned
informally before the class.
This is our central website,
with no decimal in 18086,
which will have notes coming
up, MATLAB things, problems.
That's our content.
It will be the 086 page.
OK.
So that's the course
outline in three lines.
And then the web
page and a handout
will give you half a dozen
sub-headings under those.
OK.
So that's the course.
And actually it's the center
of scientific computing.
There would be other courses
at MIT covering material
like that, because it's just so
basic you can't go without it.
All right, so now
I'm ready to start
on the first lecture, which
will be ordinary differential
equations.
And I won't always have things
so clearly and beautifully
written on the board, but
today I'm better organized.
So here's our problem.
Ordinary differential equations.
So we're given initial
values u at t equals 0.
OK.
So there's always an
initial value here.
The question is, what's the
equation that makes it evolve?
OK.
So, often we'll think in
terms of one equation.
The unknown will be u, u of t.
Or, in reality there are
typically N equations.
N might be 6 or 12 or
something in a small problem.
But also, N could be very large.
We'll see how
easily that happens.
OK.
And often, to discuss stability
or understand a method
and try it, the linear
case is the natural one.
So I'll use a*u with a small a
to make us think that we've got
a scalar, or a capital A to
indicate we're talking about
a matrix.
So, the correspondence between
these and the more general--
so these are linear.
These are likely
to be not linear.
But there's a natural
match between-- the number
a there corresponds to the
partial of f with respect to u.
And of course we see it.
If that was f, then its
derivative is indeed a.
And in this matrix case, there
would be a Jacobian matrix.
If we have N right-hand
sides, because I
have N u's, and the
matrix that comes
in is the derivative of
right-hand side in equation
i with respect to unknown j.
So it's a N by N matrix,
and of course, this
is the case where
it's a constant.
Yeah, I should have said,
these are not only linear,
but constant coefficients.
So we know of course the
solution, it's an exponential,
e to the a*t times
u_0, the initial bunch.
So we know everything about it.
Nevertheless, it's the best test
case for difference methods.
And let me just
comment that we do
have to pay attention
to the possibility
that a could be complex.
Mostly I'll think of a as
a real, and often negative.
Often the equation
will be stable.
A negative a means that
e to the a*t decreases.
A negative definite matrix,
negative eigenvalues,
mean that the matrix
exponential decays.
And if that matrix is
symmetric, those eigenvalues
are all real, that's a key case.
Symmetric matrices
have real eigenvalues,
and they're the most important,
most attractive class.
And a negative
definite matrix might
come from a diffusion term, like
second derivative, d second u,
dx squared.
But a convection term, du/dx,
from a first derivative,
will not be symmetric.
In fact, maybe it'll
be anti-symmetric.
It will push the eigenvalues
into the complex plane.
And therefore, we
have to pay attention
to the possibility of complex a.
As you know, the whole
point of eigenvalues
is that we can understand
matrices to a very large extent
by diagonalizing, by reducing
them to N scalar equations
with the eigenvalues
as the little a's
in those scalar equations.
So anyway, that's the set up.
Now I want to say
something about methods.
I want to introduce
some of the names.
What am I thinking here?
This topic, today's topic
of ordinary differential
equations, is not going
to last long in 18.086.
I might still be
discussing it tomorrow.
Friday, I mean.
But not much after that.
We'll soon be on to partial
differential equations.
So I want to sort of tell you
about ordinary differential
equations, well, in kind
of an organized way,
so that you know the
competing methods.
And also so that you
know this key distinction
between-- non-stiff
is a typical equation,
u prime equal minus 4u
would be a nonstiff,
completely normal equation.
And for that, those are the
relatively easy ones to solve.
We can use explicit differences.
And I'll say what that
word explicit means.
What I want to do is just, like,
help you organize in your mind.
So non-stiff are the average,
everyday differential
equations.
For those we can use explicit
methods that are fast.
And we can make them accurate.
And explicit means-- so
this is the first meaning--
that I compute the new U--
and I'll use capital U--
at time step n plus 1.
So that's capital
U at the new time.
Natural to call
that the new time.
Can be computed directly from
U at the old time, maybe U
at the time before that, maybe
U at the times before that.
In EE terms it's causal.
The new U comes
explicitly by some formula
that we'll construct from
the previous computations.
It's fast.
Of course, I not only use
U_n but I used f of U_n.
So I should say from U_n itself
and from f of U_n at time t_n,
and similarly for earlier times.
You see how fast that is?
Because the only new
calculation of f is this one.
The previous step produced U_n,
and at the new step, this step,
we plug it in to find
out what the slope is.
And that may be the
expensive calculation,
because f could involve all
sorts of functions, all sorts
of physical constants.
It can be complicated or not.
but if it is, we only
have to do it once here.
That's explicit.
Now, what's the opposite?
Implicit.
So the point about implicit
methods is the difference
equation, the formula,
involves not just U_(n+1),
the new value, but also the
slope at that new value,
at that new unknown value.
So it means that an implicit
equation could be non-linear.
Because if f is not linear,
then this term could involve
cosines, or exponentials
or whatever,
of the unknown U_(n+1).
So that, you can't
do it as fast.
So this is definitely
slower per step.
But, the advantage,
and the reason
it gets used for stiff problems,
is that on stiff problems
it will allow a
much larger step.
So it's this constant trade-off
of speed versus stability.
These are less
stable, as we'll see,
and we'll get to see
what stability means.
These are slower but more
stable, implicit methods.
OK.
I didn't yet say what stiff is.
I'll say that in a moment.
OK.
So explicit versus implicit.
U_(n+1) immediately or
U_(n+1) only by maybe using
Newton's method to
solve an equation,
because U_(n+1) appears
in a complicated formula.
And we have an
equation to solve.
OK.
So now, this part
of the board begins
to identify different methods.
And I'll follow the
same two-column system
that non-stiff versus stiff.
So this will be explicit
and those will be implicit.
OK.
So the one method that occurs
to everybody right away
is Euler's method.
And that will be the first
method we'll construct,
of course.
So that's the first
idea anybody would have.
It has the minimum accuracy.
It's first order.
The order of accuracy will
be an issue for all methods.
And Euler has p equal 1,
order p equal 1, first order.
So it's too crude.
I mean, if you wanted
to tracking a space
station with Euler's method,
you would lose it real fast,
or you would have to
take delta t so small
that it would be impossible.
So Euler's method is the
first one you think of,
but not the one you finish with.
And similarly on
the implicit side,
backward Euler, we'll see, is
again the first implicit method
you think of.
But in the end, you
probably want to do that.
OK.
So those are two specific
methods that are easy.
The first ones we'll write down.
Now then comes families
of methods, especially
these Adams families.
So Adams-Bashforth is explicit,
Adams-Moulton are implicit,
and the coefficients are in
books on numerical analysis
and will be on the web.
And I'll say more
about them of course.
And see the first ones.
So what Adams-Bashforth,
how does does it
differ from Adams-Moulton?
OK.
So those are multi-step methods.
Number two was
multi-step methods.
To get more accurate
we use more old values.
So Adams-Moulton
and Adams-Bashforth,
or especially Adams-Bashforth,
would use several old values
to get the order of
accuracy up high.
OK.
Now this third category.
Of course, actually
Euler would be
the first of the
Adams-Bashforth,
and backward Euler might
be early in Adams-Moulton.
Or maybe backward Euler is
early in backward differences.
OK.
So what I want to
say is, Runge-Kutta
is like a different approach
to constructing methods.
You might know what
some of these already.
And it's a one-step method.
That's a method
that just produces,
by sort of half-steps, you
could say, it gets to U_(n+1).
But it's explicit.
And the code in MATLAB,
the code ODE forty-five,
or maybe I should
say ODE four five,
is like the workhorse of ODEs.
I guess I'm hoping
you'll try that.
You'll find ODE45.
And I'll try to get
it onto the web,
but you could just easily
discover the syntax
to call it, and apply
it to an equation.
Yeah I'll get
examples on the web,
and please do the examples.
So this is-- the 4,
5 typically means
that it use a
fourth-order Runge-Kutta,
so that's pretty accurate.
To get up to a fourth
order means the error up
at time t equal 1, say,
is delta t to the fourth.
So by cutting delta t in half,
you divide the error by 16.
And then it also uses
a fifth-order one.
And maybe I can
point to these words.
What makes ODE45-- four
five-- good, successful.
I mean, how does it work?
It slows down or speeds up.
It speeds up when it can, it
slows down when it has to.
And speed up means
a bigger delta t,
slow down means a
smaller delta t,
for the sake of
stability or accuracy.
Yeah.
So if the equation is
suddenly doing something,
if the solution is
you know, important and
quick, then probably
at that period delta t will get
reduced automatically by ODE45.
It'll cut it in half, cut
in half again, half again.
Every good code is
constantly estimating,
using internal
checks to estimate
what error it's making.
About the error.
Just a quick word
about the error.
So ODE45, it will, unless
you tell it otherwise,
the default accuracy that it
will adjust for is relative.
So ODE45 will have a
relative accuracy--
so can I just squeeze in a few
words-- of 10 to the minus 3.
It'll shoot for that.
And an absolute accuracy
of 10 to the minus 6.
So it will try to
keep the error--
it will plan to keep
the error, and it'll
tell you if it has a problem,
below 10 to the minus 6.
And you could set
that differently.
OK.
I hope you experiment
a little with ODE45.
And you can either plot the
solutions, some exponential.
I mean, push it.
Like, let delta t be pretty big,
and see where it breaks down.
Well, I guess ODE45 is
engineered not to break down.
If you try a delta
t-- it'll decide
on what delta t it can do.
So we'll also
code, just quickly,
some methods by ourselves,
and see for a large delta
t, what problems could happen.
OK.
And then backwards.
This says backward differences.
That's the category of implicit
methods for stiff equation,
and backward Euler
would be the very first.
And ODE15S is the code that,
is the most used code, perhaps,
for stiff equations.
And it will do the same
thing, it will vary delta t.
It was will vary the order.
So, if it has to slow
down, it may slow.
And if things are
happening too quickly,
it may change to a low-order,
safe, secure method.
When things are, you know, when
the satellite is buzzing out
in space, and it
can take giant steps
or it can have
high-order accuracy,
say in astronomy, of
course, they would go up
to eighth order and higher,
tracking, estimating
where stars would
go or planets, these
will do that automatically,
up to a certain point.
And we could write codes,
and of course people
have, for Adams-Bashforth
and Adams-Moulton,
varying delta t, varying p.
I guess here's a comment.
If I had given this
lecture yesterday,
I would have emphasized
number two, Adams-Bashforth
and Adams-Moulton,
because books do it
and I basically
learned this subject
from the major
textbooks on ODEs.
But I had a
conversation with one
of the computational scientists
in the math department,
and that changed the lecture.
Because I learned
that although books
tend to discuss those, the
Adams methods, in practice
these methods, the methods
three-- Runge-Kutta
and backward differences--
are the most used.
And that's reflected in the fact
that these two major codes that
are available in MATLAB are
in the number three category.
OK.
So now, that's a picture with
name but not details, right?
And I haven't even
said what stiff means.
So somewhere I've written
something about stiff.
Yeah.
OK.
So stiff means--
so, if I had only
e to the minus t
in the solution,
then the solution would decay
at that rate, e to the minus t.
That time step would
adjust to keep it accurate.
And if I have only
e to the minus 99t,
then again-- that of
course is a faster decay,
much faster decay--
so the time step would
adjust to be much
smaller, probably
about 1/99 or something.
Anyway, much smaller, to
capture within each step
the correct behavior of e to
the minus 99t, and no problem.
So in other words, it's not the
minus 99 that makes it stiff.
If it was only the minus
99- in other words,
if I had a equal
minus 99 up there,
I wouldn't call it
a stiff equation.
What makes it stiff is
the combination here.
You see, what's going to happen
as time gets anywhere, this
is going to control u of t.
The decay of u of t is going
to have that time constant 1.
But this is going
to control-- so I'll
say but-- this would control
delta t for explicit methods.
And I just picked minus
99, but it could have
been minus 999 or far worse.
So it could be very stiff.
This word stiff and identifying
this class of problems, which
now is familiar to everybody
who has to compute, didn't come,
you know, with Gauss and so on.
It came much more recently.
But it's become
very important now,
to distinguish stiff
from non-stiff.
So where does stiff
problems arise?
Well you can see how they
arise in chemical processes
with very different decay
rates, biological processes,
control theory, all sorts
of cases where there's
a big dynamic range of rates.
And they also arise in systems,
because the eigenvalues
could be minus 1 and minus 99.
I can easily create a matrix
that has those two eigenvalues.
So it would be a system--
let me create such a matrix.
I think probably,
if I put minus 50's
on the diagonal, that
gives trace-- sum down
the diagonal is minus 100.
And that should equal the
sum of the eigenvalues.
So, so far so good.
And now, if I want these
two particular numbers,
I could put 49 here.
So that matrix has
those two eigenvalues.
I mean, this is
the kind of matrix,
well you might say
ill conditioned would
be a word that you hear
for a matrix like this.
The condition number
is the ratio--
so the condition
number of this matrix
would be the ratio 99 over 1.
And that condition
number is a number
that MATLAB computes
all the time.
Every time you give it a
matrix problem like this,
it estimate, not computes.
Because to compute
the condition number
requires solving an
eigenvalue problem,
and it does not want to take
forever to do that exactly.
But it gets an estimate.
So that's only a moderate
condition number of 99.
That's not a disaster,
but it makes the point.
OK.
So that's what
stiff equations are.
OK.
Now I've got one
more board prepared.
I won't have this every day, but
let me use it while I got it.
OK.
It's only prepared in
the sense of telling us
what we're going to do.
So this is what's
coming: a construction
of methods, what stability is
about, and what's convergence.
So let me begin, let me get
Euler constructed today.
And backward Euler.
So Euler's method will be
the most obvious method,
equals f at U_n.
So, in the model
case, it's a*U_n.
So that's Euler.
So that tells us then
that we could rewrite it--
U_(n+1) is explicitly
1 plus a delta t U_n.
Right?
I've moved up the delta t
and I moved over the U_n,
and it's simple like that.
OK.
So what's the solution
after n time steps?
Let me stay with
Euler for a moment.
After n steps, every
step just multiplied
by this growth factor.
Let me refer to that
as the growth factor
even if it's, as I
hope, smaller than 1.
So U_n, after n
steps, is this thing
has multiplied n times U_0.
And what is the stability now?
Stability is-- suppose a
is negative, typically.
That means-- often we'll think
of that model, a negative,
so that the differential
equation is completely stable.
Right?
e to the a*t, with a
negative, is perfect.
The question is, is
this one perfect?
So stability will be,
is this number below 1?
That's the test.
Is that-- we could argue about,
are we going to let it equal 1?
Maybe I'll let it equal 1.
So 1 plus a delta
t smaller than 1.
That'll be the stability
requirement for forward Euler.
And what's the a delta t?
What's the boundary?
What's the critical
value of a delta t?
Remember a negative.
How negative can it
be, or how negative
can this combination be?
You see, it's a
combination a delta t.
So let me put above here what
the stability condition is.
So the stability
condition on Euler
is going to be-- so
do you see what it is?
How negative can a delta t be?
Go ahead, you don't even have
to push the-- well, let's see.
So if a delta t, this
is a negative number,
so this is dragging
us down from 1 always.
Right? a delta t is like
a subtracting away from 1.
So we're here with the 1.
And a delta t is
pulling us this way.
And how far, at what point are
we going to meet instability?
Yeah.
When we hit minus 1.
This is the 1 plus a
delta t that I graphed.
So it starts at 1
with delta t equals 0.
And as I increase delta
t, it moves this way.
And eventually, it hits there.
And the limit will be at
a delta t equal minus 2.
Because if it carries me 2 from
1, that carries me to minus 1.
And if I go further,
I'm unstable.
And you could easily
check that Euler
will blow up like
crazy if you just
go a little beyond that limit.
Because you're taking
powers of a number
bigger than, or below minus 1.
OK.
So there's the stability
limit for Euler.
And that's a pretty
unpleasant restriction.
We will have other
stability limits.
We'll have some stability
limits over here,
but we're looking for
numbers better than 2.
This Adams-Bashforth will
give us numbers worse than 2.
We'll see those methods
first thing next time.
OK.
Now, let me just get back-- OK.
If I drew a picture
then-- let's see,
have I got another board here?
Nope.
If I drew a picture of good
Euler, so Euler doing its job,
the true solution is
decaying like that,
and what does Euler do?
Forward Euler says,
it looks here,
it looks at the slope,
that's all it knows,
it goes maybe that far.
That's a small delta t.
That's an OK method.
You see, it's not very
accurate of course.
It's lost all the
curvature in the solution.
So this was the true
solution e to the a*t.
And this is the 1 plus
a delta t to the power,
well, t over delta t times.
Well, no, this
was only one step,
so that would just
be 1 plus a delta t.
OK.
Where the bad, the unstable
one, if I just try to draw that,
the true solution is e
to the a*t, but I take--
I start with that value
and the right slope.
But I take too big a time
step and I'm below minus 1.
So that was a case of
a too large delta t.
OK.
Now, I've got one minute left
to mention backward Euler.
Well, that won't take me long.
I'll just change
this to U_(n+1).
So I'm evaluating the
slope at the new time.
So this is now backward
Euler, or implicit Euler.
OK.
So that changes this equation.
Oh, let's find out the
equation for implicit Euler.
OK.
I only have one more
moment, I'll just
pop it in this little corner.
So now, here's backward Euler.
All right.
You can tell me what backward
Euler is going to be.
So U_(n+1) minus U_n over
delta t is a*U_(n+1).
So let me collect
the n plus 1's.
So I have one of them.
And then minus a delta t.
Right?
And well, I bring it
over to the left side.
And here I just have U_n.
OK.
So what happens
at every step now?
I divide-- every step
is a division by this.
So I could bring this
into the denominator.
So U_n is that
division times U_0.
And you see the stability?
What's the size of
this growth factor?
Remember, I'm thinking
of a as a negative.
I'm dealing with a stable
differential equation.
And so what's the main point
about this growth factor,
this ratio in parentheses?
It is?
If a is negative, what do
I know about that number?
Think of a as
minus 2, let's say.
So then I have 1 over 1 plus 2
delta t, because it's minus a
there.
And it's going to
be smaller than 1.
Right.
It's going to be stable.
So Euler is actually absolutely
stable, backward Euler.
Backward Euler has this
property of A-stability.
There is no stability limit
on negative a, no problem.
Or even pure imaginary
a, no problem.
Always stable.
So that shows how
implicit methods
can be greatly much more
stable than explicit,
just by comparing forward
to backward Euler.
But, just to remind
you the price.
The price is that this
equation has to be solved.
Well, it wasn't any
trouble in linear case.
In the linear case
we're just inverting
a matrix for a linear system.
So backward Euler for linear
system, big linear system,
is a matrix inversion, well a
matrix linear system to solve.
But for a non-linear
problem, it's serious work.
And yet, you have to do the work
if the explicit method gives
you such a small delta t that
it's impossible to go with.
OK.
Thanks for your patience
on this first lecture.
So, obviously I'm going to have
one more discussion of ODEs,
in which we construct
these methods,
see their stability
and their convergence.
And then we move on to the PDEs.